while the president may have gotten a
boost last night from the food and drug
administration which gave doctors
emergency go-ahead to use blood plasma
from covid survivors as a coronavirus
treatment again the head of the fda
announced this emergency use
authorization at a white house
news conference yesterday as mulalengi
reports
the decision is exactly what the
president wanted
today's action will dramatically expand
access to this treatment
more than 70 000 covid patients have
already received convalescent plasma
which is taken from patients who have
recovered from the virus and whose blood
has the virus antibodies
a very historic breakthrough in our
fight against the
china virus but just last week top
doctors at the national institutes of
health
warned the fda against approving an
emergency use authorization
citing concerns that the data does not
support the decision
on saturday the president fired back and
accused the fda of slowing the process
to treat the virus
tweeting without evidence obviously they
are hoping to delay the answer until
after november third
speaking sunday fda commissioner dr
steven hahn
explained the agency's decision to go
forward with the authorization
this is not the same as an approval but
it's an authorization and allows us to
expand the access to this is there
pressure on you dr hahn to authorize
this mr dr
dr han left the press conference without
answering a reporter's question about
whether he felt pressured to issue the
authorization
in a statement to cbs news he said i've
never been asked to make any decision at
the fda
based on politics cbs news medical
contributor dr david agus
so this is not a dramatic advance but
it's an advance
the current clinical trial with the
placebo control is ongoing and we don't
yet know those results
treatment is among the major keys to
getting the country back to a sense of
normalcy but the lack of accurate
testing also remains an issue that needs
resolving
yesterday the nfl announced it's
investigating a string of false positive
covid19 tests among its players
all coming from one lab in new jersey at
least 11 teams canceled or altered
practice this weekend after some of
their players tested positive
this comes as the nfl season prepares to
kick off in less than three weeks
this isn't the perfect situation but
everybody's working through it
and you know if it ends up that it shuts
down practice you shut it down
you make sure you get it taken care of
then you ramp it back up
that was mulalengi reporting we asked
the lab for comment about the nfl's
false positive tests
but have not heard back